madame Garnier bonsoir bonsoir
Ottawa donc présente aujourd'hui
l'immigration comme étant une solution à
la grave pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est
l'expression qui est employée qui sévit
au Canada est-ce que pour vous c'est une
vraie solution
comme votre collègue l'a dit tout à
l'heure je pense que l'immigration fait
partie de la solution puisque le Canada
se trouve d'un processus de
vieillissement démographique et fait
face à un nombre record de postes
vacants donc dans ce contexte le Québec
fait pas particulièrement bonne figure
puisque la transition démographique ici
est peut-être encore plus accélérée que
dans d'autres provinces du Canada et que
on a une pénurie de main d'oeuvre très
importante que ce soit à Montréal ou
dans les régions comme ici à Québec ou
la pénurie est très forte aussi on voit
que là les cibles se portent sur
l'immigration permanente or ce qui n'a
pas été mentionné ni par les ministres
fédéraux et provinciaux ni d'autres
c'est que l'immigration temporaire
contribue considérablement à alléger les
problèmes structurels de pénurie main
d'oeuvre auxquelles on fait face et
l'immigration temporaire est très
supérieure à l'immigration permanente
aussi bien au niveau fédéral qu'au
niveau provertial mais cela dit si on
demeure sur l'immigration permanente de
passer de 400 000 en 2021 à 500 000 en
2025 est-ce que c'est réaliste comme
cible c'est une augmentation très rapide
je dirais que
ce dont il faut tenir compte pour le
moment particulièrement c'est
l'engorgement dans le délai de
traitement de l'immigration qui fait que
les gens sont très frustrés parce que ça
prend très longtemps pour atteindre le
stade de résident permanent donc je
pense que si
la volonté c'est d'accélérer cette
tendance il va falloir embaucher encore
sans doute plus de gens que ce que Shawn
freezer le ministre de l'Immigration
fédérale a déjà annoncé puisqu'il a déjà
annoncé qu'ils allaient embaucher 1950
personnes à ircc l'immigration fédérale
canadienne pour accélérer les demandes
de traitement donc forcément je pense
que ça va si il pense faire ça au sein
de la bureaucratie il va falloir
accélérer les traitements pour ce qui
est du reste et du fonctionnement de la
société de l'économie par exemple les
logements etc encore une fois il y a
beaucoup plus d'immigrants temporaires
déjà donc ça ce sont des choses dont il
faut tenir compte mais c'est pas jeudi
ça va ça va être de toute façon beaucoup
plus au niveau des personnes qui sont
sur les territoires que les chiffres de
l'immigration permanente quand le
gouvernement dit que l'immigration est
nécessaire pour avoir une croissance
économique durable est-ce que c'est
exact
je vois pas très bien comment faire sans
l'immigration parce que sans
l'immigration il faut savoir que les
entreprises canadiennes comparées à la
moyenne des pays de l'océdieux
investissent très peu pour augmenter
pour moderniser par exemple investissent
très peu en capital c'est surtout sur
l'immigration qu'il mise hors il y a des
études qui montrent que si on accélère
beaucoup l'investissement à capital
c'est encore plus cher que faire venir
des immigrants dans les entreprises donc
si on veut faire autrement il faudrait
complètement revoir le modèle économique
en fait canadien
la nouvelle ministre de l'Immigration du
Québec Christine Frechette dit que c'est
le Québec qui doit déterminer ces cibles
le seuil de 50000 et celui qui respecte
la capacité d'accueil de francisation
d'intégration à la lumière de cette
annonce là est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement logo devra revoir ses
cibles je pense que le gouvernement logo
devrait déjà définir ce qui n'entend ta
capacité d'accueil parce que ça il ce
n'est pas défini ça a été aussi montré
dans des choses qui ont été mises à jour
par des journalistes de Radio-Canada et
c'est quelque chose d'important ensuite
il faut voir est-ce que c'est vraiment
dans l'intérêt du Québec d'avoir un
décalage aussi important entre le reste
du Canada et du Québec puisque si
l'immigration croit moins vite ici on se
prend place dans un système
démographique où le Québec a un poids
démographique moins important et donc
perd aussi du poids politique puisque ça
diminue par exemple il y a des enjeux en
termes de nombre de sièges pour la
représentation du Québec au Parlement
donc c'est pas juste une question
économique auquel on fait face mais même
sur le plan économique pour le moment
si on se tourne vers d'autres choses il
faut revoir en profondeur le modèle de
l'économie et ça moi j'ai pas beaucoup
entendu des voix s'élevées pour avoir
une autre vision économique que celle
que l'on défend pour le moment et aussi
pour moi c'est très important de le dire
en tant qu'immigrantes moi-même les
immigrants sont des humains il
contribuent à la société à la culture et
à l'économie si on n'arrête pas de dire
qu'il y a un problème en termes de
capacité d'accueil ça peut être
interprété par les immigrants comme
est-ce que c'est une est-ce que ici les
immigrants sont moins bien
venus que dans le reste du Canada par
exemple ce sont des questions
importantes sur lesquelles réfléchir un
dernier mot le Québec on sait demande
plus de pouvoir sur le plan de
l'immigration il y a un accord également
entre tawa et l'Ontario qui vient
échéance bientôt et l'Ontario veut les
mêmes pouvoirs que le Québec en matière
d'immigration en même temps l'Ontario
veut doubler le nombre des migrants
économiques que la province reçoit
est-ce que le plan fédéral d'aujourd'hui
va faire l'affaire de l'Ontario selon
vous
c'est une bonne question je pense que
c'est l'Ontario est en avant maintenant
mais d'autres provinces demandent aussi
à renégocier leurs accords entre le
fédéral et provincial notamment le
Manitoba et je pense que ce serait dans
l'intérêt d'Ottawa d'augmenter encore
plus le pouvoir qui sont donnés aux
provinces dans l'accueil des immigrants
économiques puisque les provinces aussi
recherchent en particulier certains
types d'immigrants par contre
Ottawa a un intérêt à ce qu'il y ait pas
une trop forte compétition et que les
immigrants se rendent pas tous dans une
province au dépend d'autres provinces
donc le jeu est assez difficile par
contre il faut aussi voir que la
politisation de l'immigration est plus
forte au Québec que dans le reste du
Canada donc c'est à suivre Adèle gardien
merci pour cette analyse ce soir c'est
moi qui vous remercie